5 55 what's driving you crazy oh no
say it isn't so oh so
blanca that is where the 95 meets the
northern 215 beltway come on let's go
centennial polling
now faithful viewers may recall we've
talked about this more than once the
frontage road
that runs just west of the 95 getting a
huge makeover as part of the project's
final face but for others
well a message signed by the side of the
road north of the 215 it has been a
shocking wake-up call
oso blanca to close february 7th
for three years yeah your eyes are lying
blanca will close february 7th at super
bowl sunday for
three years as seen in this video from
the 8 news now drone the street that
runs under
elkhorn next to mountain ridge park down
to the 215
is no longer an exit from the beltway
for now the new and improved oso blanca
itself is going to run
under the 215 but and all is said and
done
there will be non-beltway connections
both north and
south of the 215 between oso blanca and
sky point on the other side of the 95
until then
here are the recommended detours for
southbound drivers take durango to the
215 for access either obviously to the
beltway or to the south 95
for northbound drivers you're gonna have
to get used to using the 95 to get onto
the beltway
west and then go over to durango going
to be a huge one for
three years now all of this information
is on our website eightnewsnow.com you
click traffic than driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone if there's
something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8
8 news now dot com john